northern france the stage for a quiet
battle
against covid
mass testing of the local population
there's one quick test to establish if
you've got coronavirus
and then a second more accurate test
supposed to detect
the new mutation normally referred to
here
as the english variant
was hit badly a few months ago there is
anxiety here that this new variant could
plunge the town back into
grave trouble down the road
we visit jean philippe the town's deputy
mayor and also a doctor
he is weary and wary of kovid
in the southern city of marseille
firefighters have been testing watering
drains
to chart the spread of this new variant
france already has strict lockdown rules
and a curfew
the arrival of the new strain has led to
calls for rules to be tightened
and it isn't just about the french the
point about this new variant is the
speed
at which both the virus and the fear can
spread
whether you call it the british the uk
or the english variant this new
covert mutation is stretching nerves
across europe brussels is the heart of
european politics diplomats come
in and out of this city all the time and
it is that
movement of people that is causing
anxiety
van ranst is the most prominent
virologist in belgium an adviser to the
government
and now worried that britain's crisis is
coming to his country
if the transmissibility is really 50 70
percent higher than the wild-type strain
then everybody should be worried because
that means that an epidemic that was
under control
might be getting again out of control
and um
well you don't want that and when you
say
out of control what does what does that
mean in in real life
terms other control means the situation
in london
as we speak if you have to treat
patients in ambulances because there are
no bets available
that's pretty much out of control
europe's vaccination program trails
behind the uk but it is speeding up
there was a sense of optimism but now
with the arrival of this new variant the
continent is gripped once again by the
fear
of what is to come adam parsons sky news
brussels